Brady has given me a Christmas present
this is so-called artificial snow or
sodium polyacrylate it's a white powder
if I put a little bit on the desk and
what happens with this and white people
like it is that it absorbs water very
easily I've got some water here and
since it's just water I can do the
experiment in my office
so are you ready we'll try and see what
happens if you pour a bit of water on
this you can see it swells up probably I
didn't put enough bit more and it feels
very like snow can even dribble it onto
my DNA Christmas tree that I was given
as a Christmas present perhaps we should
try the experiment on a larger scale so
I've got beaker here and we put let's
put the lot in this material is famous
for its absorption of water so if we put
in some water here you can see it really
swells up if we stir it up it then
starts expanding even more the reason
why this stuff works is because it is a
sodium salt it is so-called acrylic acid
which is a small molecule which has been
polymerized so you've joined a whole
series of acrylic acid molecules
together to form a chain and because
it's an acid it can be reacted with
sodium to make the sodium salt and the
chains because the way the polar is made
are actually linked together so that
they can't easily separate so when you
add water just like too many other
sodium salts it absorbs water and the
sodium ion na+ gets water going round it
to hydrate it gives out energy and if it
was sodium chloride the crystal
structure would just collapse and it
would all dissolve but because these
organic chains are joined together and
interlinked they can't dissolve the
powder each grain is almost like a large
molecule and so it just swells up and
this has all sorts of practical
applications it's used particularly in
babies nappies or as you would say in
the United States diapers where you want
to absorb the liquid and keep the baby
dry so you put some of this material
inside a pad and so the liquid goes
through the pad and swells up and the
baby stays dry you can use it for other
absorbent materials as well but it is a
very simple material and it's fun to use
at Christmas so let's make it snow a bit
more let it snow 200 mils of water and
we will try a new fresh containment this
one may be better because all being well
it won't be able to block the beaker in
the way so it's snowing quite nicely
makes a terrible mess so who's going to
clean that up me
everybody else has finished for
Christmas so can't even rely on Neal to
clean it up this time so happy Christmas
to all of our viewers and look forward
to some really exciting videos for 2015
and a Happy New Year to you all and
enjoy your chemistry